when published continue in the spirit of
this session with Pat actually use of
one computer to solve some of the
problems that we just heard about thank
you James
and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me to this conference as well
as thank you to Nathan and Martin who
sort of teed up my talk very nicely for
me today so the goal is to sort of give
an overview of this topic of simulating
chemistry with quantum computers which
is sort of an expansive thing at this
point so I'll do my best
but let's start with this so as you know
the world is made of atoms and chemistry
sort of emerges from the interactions of
electron to those atoms and so I sort of
believe that simulating systems of
interacting electrons on quantum
computers is kind of an ideal
application and that's because at least
in some circumstances for instance in
transition metals places with strong
correlation these problems are very
challenging classically yet they're
extremely important there's lots of
interesting applications so to give some
sense and you know maybe this isn't with
Martin's you know state of the art
methods necessarily but using methods
where you can sort of carefully control
the air you know might take you seconds
on a laptop to solve exactly for the
wave function of methane ethane maybe
minutes and again using something like
exact diagonalization maybe days for
something like propane and there's
certainly a lot of ground between
propane and something like an atomistic
description of a superconductor and you
know certainly we'd be interested in in
cases in between those two extremes so I
think the prospect of more efficient
solutions in this area is very exciting
both scientifically so and it's also
valuable so you know an application that
comes to mind for a lot of people when
you talk about chemistry is
pharmaceuticals and there probably are
some applications there maybe in
developing catalysts for better you know
synthesis or something like this
but other areas like catalysts for
industrial processes like fertilizer
production or for looking at say metal
cathodes and batteries or perhaps better
OLEDs for you know this phone that
Google produces or something like this
these would all be interesting
applications for this sort of thing so
as Martin introduced very well we're
going to be speaking about the molecular
electronic structure problem mostly
today so we have electrons and
Tong's and they interact via the Coulomb
interaction they have real kinetic
energy but we're going to be clamping
those nuclei under the born-oppenheimer
approximation so as Martin talks about
sort of in depth the concept of an
energy surface is well-defined and
chemists are you know quite interested
in these energy surfaces because they
allow us to understand reactions and
also predict mechanisms of chemical
processes and in particular we're often
looking for very high accuracy in
differences in energies on these
surfaces because those differences in
energies give us chemical rates and in
fact they're exponentially sensitive
such that at room temperature we're
looking for some fixed add of air of
something like 1 kcal per mole in the
total energy and so in in some cases
maybe often is the wrong word but in
some cases this is certainly classically
intractable and that's especially true
for systems with strong correlation I
should also mention I won't really have
time to get into this but we should
really also be thinking about using
quantum computers as sort of an act of
space or impurity solver just for the
most strongly correlated parts of the
problem in most cases you'll be treating
lots of the environment with lower
levels of theory of things like the FT
things like this all right so now I'm
going to talk a bit about how we
actually put this problem on a qualm
computer so we are playing a wave
function on a computer so we're gonna
have to discretize space to some extent
we're gonna have to combine confine
these electrons to a basis so a common
basis that's used in classical
electronic structure is molecular
orbitals so these are single particle
solutions from the sort of mean field
solution to the electronic structure
problem if we have let's say 8 electrons
confined to end locations and basis
functions like this there's of course
and choose a de configurations so the
wavefunction may span a combinatorially
many configurations and so in the most
straightforward encoding that is
actually what we typically think about
in practice in quantum computing we're
just going to have one qubit for each
orbital basically and the qubit is one
if there's an electron there and it's
zero if there's not so you know this
configuration would mean that there's no
electrons in these two but there's an
electron here and the electron here and
so this you know method of kind of
labeling what space is occupied instead
of saying
which electrons are where is Court is
consistent with the sort of second
quantized representation of electronic
structure and there's different ways
that one can obtain the actual discord
ization of the hamiltonian but perhaps
the most common in electronic structure
is what's called a choleric and
discretization where you take integrals
over these basis functions which define
the Hamiltonian that looks something
like this
where these things are fermionic rates
and they're lowering operators so for
instance a dagger PAQ that's an operator
that transitions an excitation from
sites from orbital Q to orbital P and
this is you know with of course it's in
a finite basis but up to the finite
basis and you know up to relativistic
effects this is the exact many-body
Hamiltonian so I should point out that
these operators they are fermionic
operators they act on fermions not
cubits cubits are distinguishable
particles of no special symmetry
fermions are anti-symmetric and
indistinguishable and so for instance in
second quantization our operators have
to meet certain anti commutation
relations over in here which means that
if you wish to write down a Hamiltonian
the acts on qubits you need to find some
you know sort of isomorphism that
matches this algebra you need to find
some cubed operators that have these
commutation relations there's a number
of techniques for doing that one of them
is Jordan big nur which just you know
provides a simple mapping to cubed
operators it looks like this all right
so now we have a qubit Hamiltonian but I
actually want to point out for a moment
that this Hamiltonian has a rather large
number of terms from my perspective it
as end of the fourth terms in it which
is we'll talk about later that's sort of
a large number of terms for kalam
simulation algorithms so I want to spend
a moment talking about ways that you
could represent this Hamiltonian using
fewer terms in particular just this one
slide I'll devote to talking about this
paper which was the recent PR X we had
where we basically found basis sets that
allowed us to write the Hamiltonian in
form that looked like this which had
only n squared terms and discuss some
associated quantum algorithms but
basically the particular basis says that
we looked at they looked something like
this there were some sort of a smooth
approximation to a grid that actually
came from unit
rotation of plane waves which is worth
speaking about as well because plane
waves are periodic so this is sort of a
natural basis to look at periodic
systems like crystals or graphene which
is periodic and 2d polymers which are
periodic and 1d things like that of
course you need more plane waves than
say Gaussian atomic orbitals to model
single molecules and that factor might
be large it might be you know a factor
of 20 or 40 or something depending on
you know how you're using things like
pseudo potentials but it's not an
asymptotic factor for those computer
scientists and they're wondering I
should also point out though that there
are a lot of people for instance Linlin
here at Berkeley or Steve why UCI who
have been doing a lot of recent work on
developing basis functions that have
that are more compact or maybe not more
compact but have higher resolution and
yet also give you a form that looks like
this with fewer terms so you might want
to check that out but with a molto naeun
like this after you map it to qubits
it's very structured it has n squared
terms but there's also a lot of
structure in it so for instance we had
this recent PRL showing that you could
simulate try our steps of this
Hamiltonian in linear depth even a non
linearly connected array sorry I'm sorry
and is the number of basis functions or
equivalently the number of qubits
because we have one qubit for each spin
orbital in this case alright so the rest
of this talk is going to be sort of
about algorithms we've talked about
representations and I'm going to talk
about both algorithms sort of for
fault-tolerant devices and one's
applicable for the near-term so first
I'll talk about what I would kind of
call the canonical quantum algorithm for
chemistry so the key to this approach is
to sort of leverage the fact that
classical methods say mean field methods
or other methods martin talked about
allow us to prepare initial states that
have some reasonable overlap on the
ground states of interest so for
instance if we're interested in
preparing and measuring the energy of
say eigenstate k we should be able to
start the simulation in some state side
that has some reasonable overlap on the
ground state and i'll talk i'll justify
that a bit in on the next slide here if
we can do that the next step is to
we construct some quantum circuit which
encodes in its eigenvalues the
eigenvalues of the hamiltonian so for
instance one such encoding would be the
time evolution operator you can use
various methods we'll discuss to
synthesize the time evolution operator
which would encode the eigenvalues of
the Hamiltonian another common one which
we'll also talk about would be say a
quantum walk that looks something like
this
so if you think about applying a circuit
let's just take the time evolution one
is an example to this initial state sigh
then you know quantum mechanics 101 here
you can just sort of expand what's going
on in the eigen basis of the Hamiltonian
and you can see that what's happening is
that you know you're the output state is
a superposition of the eigenstates of
the Hamiltonian that are picking up some
phase that depends on which eigenstate
it is and so in fact in this case that
phase will directly encode the energy of
the system that you're interested in and
so because of that property you can use
the quantum phase estimation algorithm
to measure that phase and in fact you
can use it in a projective fashion so
that when you measure the phase that
projects you also to an eigenstate of
the operator and in particular you're
going to be project you're going to
measure you know the phase associated
with eigenstate K with the probability
that goes with the squared overlap of
the initial state and eigenstate K and
in general for phase estimation you're
going to require one over epsilon
coherent repetitions of this unitary if
you're interested in measuring that out
to you know precision epsilon and you
know epsilon will be a small number for
chemistry because we want high accuracy
so one over epsilon isn't a small number
of repetitions which is why I believe
that you'll really need a quantum error
correction for this sort of algorithm
okay so I have one slide now about just
the first step about preparing in
initial States so I have I'm going to
show a little bit of data which is from
a paper by a number of folks here at
Berkeley including norm Tubman and
actually Martin who just spoke this will
be out kind of soon but basically we
used a method which is called ASCI which
we believe converges it's a classical
method which converges the support of
the wavefunction on the first few
determinants much faster than the total
energy so it provides a nice mekin
and we think for looking at say what is
the support of these initial states on
the ground state and so this is a number
of this is kind of a you know some
canonical data set of rather small
molecules many organics frankly these
are mostly things DFT you would probably
do fairly well on but we see that they
are in fairly large basis sets so over
100 cubits in some instances and we see
that we actually have in most cases over
80 percent overlap which is way more
than we need I mean we would be fine
with 0.1 or 0.01 overlap or something
like this so we're doing quite well here
and I might also point out for those who
know what this is you could also use
these estimates of the overlap for
amplitude amplification but I should
point out that you know some molecules
once they have strong correlation maybe
it stretched configurations they're not
going to have as good of support so we
looked at some of those instances for
instance the nitrogen in chromium dimer
which had pretty good support at
equilibrium but when they were stripped
stretched it turns out you actually a
very low support on just one
configuration but were you to create
your initial state as a superposition of
just the first few important
configurations then you very quickly
recover overlap on the wave function and
what's nice is you can prepare a super
arbitrary superposition of OWL states
with teague a complex do of L that's
kind of straightforward to work out and
so we're talking about 60 determinants
or something here this is an additive
cost to phase estimation so you know we
believe that we can do this and it's
essentially free because phase
estimation is much more expensive okay
so now let's move on to the next part
which is about how we actually encode
the spectra in these circuits and first
I'll talk about doing that with trotter
so of course time evolution based on
trotter ization nathan spoke about
should be kind of familiar to a number
of you you have a Hamiltonian that you
can write the sum of local amyl Toni ins
like this and trotter is a ssin in its
simplest form the first order formula
would be you just you know simulate
these terms one after another and sort
of repeat that for a number of steps now
trotter is a Chanel scaling that is
polynomial in the inverse precision and
obviously also polynomial in the number
of terms in the Hamiltonian because you
need to sort of simulate them one at a
time a question though is how many
Trotter steps do you need and you know
there's been a number of work on this
specifically in the context of chemistry
which have shown
fairly poor scaling in terms of
analytical bounds that suggests this
would be a very bad idea but then we
actually do simulations empirically and
find that we have much less trotter
error than you might think but also we
have this issue with the simulations
being very instant specific it can be
kind of hard to get broad trends here so
just to show some very actually ancient
numerix at this point here are some kind
of small molecules and I'm plotting the
worst trotter error that could be
induced on any state for that molecule
it's a function of the number of spin
orbitals you get some weird trend well
you know it turns out things like
chemical properties often do matter in
determining things like trotter errors
here's a plot of the same data against
the maximum nuclear charge which is not
the thing a computer scientists would
normally think of as N and oh look now
it's a line but this is the worst air
that could be induced on any state but I
don't want to simulate any state I want
to simulate the ground state and I look
at the ground state now I got some mess
that looks like this I don't really see
a very clear trend I do see that the air
is much less than what these bounds on
the normative suggested to me so the
conclusion is I think that trotter
ization may actually be very practical
and very effective but my expectation is
that on the first fault-tolerant devices
people are going to use it in what a
computer scientists might consider a
sort of unsafe heuristic mode I think
people are gonna kind of guess how many
charge steps are required maybe make
some little arguments to try to convince
you that it is you know the trier errors
converged maybe it is maybe it isn't and
we'll learn things and sometimes they'll
be appropriate and sometimes not but you
know if you're upset by that then you'll
really be a fan of these sort of post
trotter methods which are certainly more
precise in my in my opinion more
interesting and they are often faster
for chemistry so for instance Nathan
spoke about these linear combination of
unitary methods for and also you know
instantiations of that using qubit
ization which can scale sub linearly in
both the number of hamiltonian terms and
in 1 over epsilon and so in this method
we choose dr the amal tonin as a linear
combination of unit ares which is
straightforward to do of course because
you know the second quantized
Hamiltonian map to qubits is already in
this form and then we need these two
oracle circuits we need two circuits
that do this and you know the simulation
people don't tell you how to
that's up to you you have to come up
with an instantiation of these but one
of the circuits action on this register
that indexes the number of terms in the
Hamiltonian as well as on psy and it
selectively applies one of the terms in
the Hamiltonian to psy controlled on L
the other one it creates some state on
this and Silla register here it creates
a state which is a superposition
weighted by the coefficients of the
terms in the Hamiltonian and there's
some normalization factor lambda there
and you know the sort of general result
of qubit ization essentially is that
with one query to this circuit and two
queries to this circuit one can create a
quantum walk which realizes this
operator essentially now if you were
going to do phase estimation as we are
you can just stop at that point you
don't actually need to do signal
processing to convert this into e to the
i HT because you could just phase
estimate on that and then take the
cosine of your answer and it works just
as well the real question is how do you
implement U and G for chemistry so we
had a paper at a with a paper with
Dominic Baria you know three years ago
now where we we did show you know that
one could implement U and G both with
linear gate complexity but I should warn
you that our method of implementing G
the state preparation thing was really
just for fun it was highly impractical
because it involved computing the
integrals defining the glare Candice
Croatian on the fly
and so that was interesting but it
wasn't very practical at all you should
you know Assam tox isn't the end of
everything but very recently last month
we had another paper which focused on
these simpler representations of the
Hamiltonian with N squared terms which
allowed us to get a very practical
linear gate complexity and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a moment
in general with these methods one is
going to need to repeat the procedure a
number of times scaling as this
normalization factor and I should also
point out that some other very recent
work that Nathan didn't really have time
to talk about but the signal processing
work sort of provides a mechanism where
one can kind of hand wavy way of saying
it is it provides a way one can kind of
lower what this lambda parameter is
because you can think of the Hamiltonian
as 2
opponents T and V and you sort of
simulate in the frame of one or the
other of them and so instead of having
to make lambda T plus lambda V queries
you can end up making a number of
queries scaling like polynomial E and
only one of those things but not both of
them and so that can be very effective
for chemistry all right so this is this
talk was normally about realistic qualms
computers so you know it's important
than to talk about what may be a good
cost model for these algorithms is so
again I said that these algorithms I
think you you're going to need error
correction for and because of that I
think that counting T gates is a pretty
good cost model so T gates tend to come
from arbitrary rotations and also from
TOEFL ease and implementing a T gate
within these say most topological codes
in two dimensions such as the surface
code requires something like a tea
factory a place where magic states are
distilled which allows you to apply tea
gates and so it's some horrible thing
that looks like this if you know it a
topological you know surface code
diagram looks like and the first error
corrected devices are probably only
gonna have one of these things because
these things consume a lot of logical
qubits maybe eighty to a hundred logical
qubits which might be as big as your
whole system register because you're
only going to have one of them you're
probably gonna distill these T State
these magic states in series which means
that your whole algorithm is gonna
bottleneck waiting for these one these
gates to be produced in fact these T
gates will probably be a hundred to a
thousand times slower than a Clifford
gate so you can in most cases for the
earth for the first generation of fault
tolerant devices just sort of think of
Clifford gates as free and just worry
about this so in the interest of time
I'm not gonna actually really talk much
about this I have this table or I've
sort of tabulated how the T gates and
various approaches to this problem have
come down over time you know recently
we've made some progress getting down to
n to the third and then N squared with
signal processing but I do want to warn
you the asymptotic complexity can be
misleading in fact the authors of this
signal of this interaction picture paper
would agree in fact of the particular
way they do this for chemistry will have
some very high constant factors that for
instance make it probably not
competitive for the first aircraft ed
devices
with the algorithm of about above it so
anyways it's important to actually count
t gates for these algorithms
unfortunately very few papers have done
this because it's very tedious to do so
the first paper to do this was this
Microsoft work was published in peanuts
which looked specifically at Oh wasn't
it published in PS oh and mine is Fe - s
- okay you just liked it alright so ok
it was 108 cubed active space right ok
so it wasn't that molecule I apologize
but it was 180 would active space they
found that you needed roughly 10 to the
15 T gates to solve it which is a lot of
T gates they used the arbitrary basis
representation the gouge and orbitals
with trotter ization which had a sort of
formal end of the eight scaling but
something more like an empirical end of
the six scaling the only other paper to
do this was this one that we had last
month that used you know it didn't
actually require a specific basis but a
basis that diagonalizes the coulomb
operators such as plane waves as well as
the qubit ization techniques our method
at end of the three scaling we also went
a bit further than the clifford + t and
compiled all the ball next to surface
code fault-tolerant gates so we actually
made these braiding diagrams which was
sort of an interesting experience and we
also use some automatic compilation
tools to layout the entire algorithm and
the surface code now I'm going to show
some results from that but I want to
explain one thing quickly which is that
in these linear combination of unitary
algorithms unlike in the trotter
algorithms the cost ends up being much
less sensitive to the particular
instance you can kind of quantify the
cost just in terms of how many basis
functions it doesn't really matter
exactly what the instance is so for
instance the other cost only enters
through this lambda parameter which I'm
showing I don't know how well you can
see that but for a couple different
materials here diamond graphing lithium
and it's all pretty similar but anyways
these were some of the results that we
found so here we're saying how big the
instance is here how many T gates you
can see a you know over 128 qubits we
have only 200 million T gates which is
about five million times
less than that and so air rates of 10 to
minus 3 which is what we've been able to
achieve and hardware on devices so far
you'd need about 2 million physical
qubits to do that but that's those
layouts are based on what we could
compile with existing software tools my
collaborator Austin Fowler was very much
a stickler about this we actually
believe we can reduce the physical
qubits by a factor of at least 10 just
by doing better compilation between the
Clifford plus T layer and the surface
code fault tolerant gate layer and that
would be by using techniques like
lattice surgery or for instance reducing
the number of physical qubits used to
encode a logical qubit and the logical
qubit isn't being acted on but we
haven't implemented those things in
software yet so Austin wouldn't let me
put that in the paper so anyways we have
run times measured in hours so you know
this is getting less crazed than it used
to be we believe that we can use this
approach to simulate you know whatever
molecule I guess it's not Fe 2s2 but you
know Momoko however I should say that we
need to sort of develop better basis
functions for that because we're not
going to use a hundred and you know
twenty-eight plane wave to get a good
description of that we were aware of
this but we are doing a lot of work now
in basis functions that are compatible
with these algorithms but also give
better representations so I'm going a
little bit slow here I'll speed it up a
bit but the second part of my talk I was
going to talk about these sort of
variational approach to solving problems
in quantum chemistry so this is based on
the variational algorithm and the idea
is that you have some parametrized
quantum state which you sort of measure
its energy and you adjust those
parameters to try to minimize the energy
basically and this is a heuristic
algorithm it's a hybrid quantum
classical algorithm so the idea is you
have some state preparation a
measurement step on the quantum computer
and then you have some variational
optimization which occurs on the
classical computer so again the first
step is you want to cleverly
parameterize some short climb circuit
with you know presumably a polynomial
number of variables this is a very
important step you need to think
carefully about how you're
parameterizing this if you want to work
you know then you apply this circuit
some guest state may be your best
classical state like you know
hartree-fock state or something better
and then you measure its energy and then
you use a classical optima
to suggest new parameters and this is
sort of a closed feedback loop here so
this approach has been demonstrated in a
number of experiments in the first
experiment they got some you know this
data was a little bit noisy maybe this
was on a photonics platform from the
Bristol group in 2015 we did both the
the QE experiments which is in red dots
which did pretty well and the phase
estimation experiment the one that I
said needed their correction which
didn't do well cuz it needs air
correction and we got chemical accuracy
in the dissociation energy there so that
we thought was good here's another
experiment that came from the Berk from
sadiki's group here at Berkeley they
looked at some excited states and some
air mitigation stuff to here's some
other curves on an ion trap they use
some different bases IBM they did this
for molecular hydrogen their data looked
kind of ok and then they did it for
lithium hydride they did it looked kind
of not okay but then they sort of
redeemed themselves recently they put
another paper out last month where they
did some air medication techniques and
now their lithium hydride curve looks
qualitatively ok so anyways you know
we're going the still small molecules
but we're getting bigger here so that's
all good so I just wanted to this is
actually my last slide about the
variational stuff so the big question is
from sort of an algorithms perspective
how do you parameterize these things
what you shouldn't do is you shouldn't
use a random quantum circuit which is
what a lot of people have been talking
about in fact you can prove that random
circuits due to concentration to measure
have a problem where you're going to see
exponential scaling to be able to
resolve any sort of gradient or do the
minimization so you should you should
try to use some method that captures
some structure and the problem so one of
the first proposals was a unitary couple
cluster so Mark Martin spoke a bit about
couple cluster and unitary couple
cluster is a sort of circuit which is a
unitary equivalent of that and in fact
it actually fixes some of the
shortcomings of the traditional couple
cluster in particular this is a strictly
variational method whereas classical a
couple cluster isn't so you can't get
divergent energies and furthermore it's
a trivially multi reference form of them
meaning it's very straightforward to
just apply it to whatever superposition
you
initially and it works just as well so I
think it's actually a very powerful
approach and a very good idea but the
problem is for near-term devices it's
quite costly it looks like there's you
know end of the fourth gates or
something like this and that and that
doesn't feel very near-term to me
another approach which looks a bit more
practical is what I would call Trotter
eyes de dia back state preparation and
so here the idea is you pretend you're
going to you know digitize a dia back
state preparation with Trotter but you
say I don't have the budget for that
many gates so I'm just going to take not
enough Trotter steps and that seems to
work pretty well we've seen in numerix
and so I think that's kind of a
promising approach it has you know a lot
of the structure of the Hamiltonian
cooked into it you have a good strategy
for initial guesses and so forth so it's
sort of based on real time evolution
it's similar in this sense and principle
to the quantum approximate optimization
algorithm and maybe a kind of trivial
statement is it works well if you're
adiabatic path that your digitizing is
gapped so for instance if you can start
in some initial state that's in the same
phase as the final state and you can
sort of interpolate through a reasonable
path so that was all I really think I
had time to say about that I think a
good cost model for variational
algorithms because this is intrinsically
a near-term sort of thing is to think
about circuit depth and you know because
it's a little bit arbitrary to choose a
particular two qubit gate like a cz or C
na gate maybe thinking about it in terms
of arbitrary two qubit gates which also
makes sense because you know we're also
in our group thinking a lot about tuning
up gates sort of at a level of microwave
pulses and we think we can essentially
realize arbitrary to give a gate so if
you can merge single qubit gates into
your two qubit gates then why wouldn't
you do this so I've listed here how the
depths of sort of structured variational
on thoughts that people care about has
sort of improved throughout the years
and I'll note that as I mentioned the
sort of these N squared hamiltonian
representations admit a n depth charge
step on even on a linear array of qubits
which is something that I think is
pretty exciting
I had like conclusion slide by knew I
was going to go over time so I got rid
of it so this is actually my last slide
which is just sort of this promotion
for what I call an electronic structure
package for quantum computers you should
check it out if you're interested in
this sort of thing it's a tool for it's
all open source it's a tool for
obtaining these hamiltonians and mapping
them to qubits and compiling them to
circuits and it works with a number of
electronic structure packages we'd love
to have it work with Q chem currently
works with pi ICF and sy4 but you know
it we have a lot of collaborators here
it's growing so you should think about
contributing so that that was it
actually that's something you should ask
John Martinez tomorrow but I mean it's
obviously something that we would we'd
need to compile ahead of time it turns
out that for for instance for the
particular qualm chemistry simulations
we have if you look at this paper
there's actually a very particular to
cuba gate that we would need to do the
simulation so we'd only really need to
tune-up one gate but it's not a gate
that has a name like IC not gate or
something oh yeah
well the connectivity matters on your
term devices when I say arbitrary I I
don't I don't mean forget about
connectivity I think that you should
absolutely if you're working in the near
term my opinion is you need to develop
algorithms from the beginning that are
aware of the topology of your chip or
it's just not going to work you I don't
think you're gonna be able to develop an
algorithm on a arbitrary device and then
compile it to your restricted
connectivity thing there will be too
much overhead so I think the way to go
is sort of what's done in this paper for
instance where we think from the
beginning okay we have a restricted
connectivity how do we design an
algorithm around that
and it's good to see that you get away
with like in square terms for the
interaction term and the quantum
chemistry problem by choosing the right
time orbitals yourself people and what
about for but is it obviously not eaten
up by the three factors this depends
this depends yeah this depends a lot on
the on the system you're simulating and
it also depends on the the particular
basis that you're using so for instance
I can tell you know this is maybe an
esoteric example but for instance the
uniform electron gas which is a system
people are interested in the natural
orbitals for that our plane waves are
this basis so it's better than gaussians
so for instance Steve white who were
working with now has been developing
these basis sets that he calls gal slits
their wavelet transforms of gaussians
and he's been able to show that the Gao
slits have he's only looked so far on
hydrogen rings and hydrogen chains but
that's sort of a real chemical system
that has the feel of of chemistry and
for those systems he has almost the same
resolution of Gaussian orbitals meaning
the factor is substantially less than
two between the two basis sets that get
comparable accuracy so in that sense we
think this is very encouraging and then
also when Lin is is here too is working
on some related methods that he calls
disk discontinuous choleric and methods
which also you know give similar forms
to this Hamiltonian but with much higher
resolution than say plane waves and also
for periodic systems you often want
plane waves and you shouldn't pretend
periodic systems aren't important I mean
there's a lot of important problems and
materials so you know for single
molecules there's certainly quite an
overhead I don't think play I don't
think on any near-term device especially
anyone's gonna use plane waves and come
out ahead of gaussians but I'll also
point out and I didn't want to talk too
much about this because I don't like
people scooping me but we're working a
lot on algorithms in first quantization
to do with an error correction right now
and in first quantization the number of
basis functions you get is exponential
in the number of qubits so if I have
twenty cubits I have a million plain
ways million plain waves is starting to
pretty good clarify this question of
Joey so far this is functions this is a
heuristic oh okay so the as far as the
the basis set scaling the basis that
disk root is ation air is fundamentally
limited by so the reason gaussians are
better well they have lower constant
factors is because they can resolve the
cusps in the wave function of the nuclei
very well so the wave function has a
cusp of the nuclei because you know
electron right
well but so I'm about to get to the
asymptotic part here so the constant
factor comes from their ability to
resolve this cusp of the nuclei but it
turns out that there's ways with both
plane waves and gaussians of suppressing
the nuclear cusp
very well you can use pseudo potentials
or you can do other things that work
very well the gaussians can get steeper
and steeper the thing that actually
limits the asymptotic convergence though
is the electron-electron cusp so the
electron-electron cusp occurs at all
points in space so it's actually very
diffuse and asymptotically no single
particle basis function has an
asymptotic and resolving that they're
all sort of similarly inadequate and
kind of Basques algebraic convergence
like 1 over n so so the the rate at
which use of perhaps arrow due to the
electron electron cusp is asymptotically
1 over N for either plane waves or for
gaussians so asymptotically the basis
set air converges the same it's a
constant factor difference not
necessarily as you know could be a
factor of 50 or something especially for
small molecules I'm not really a fan of
plane ways I'm a fan of these diagonal
Coulomb operators so just depend on the
way you do this job you know
yeah well it depends on the algorithm
that you're taking so for instance there
are some other transformations like
there's this Private Eye of
transformation which gives log and local
operators instead of and local so say in
the near term for doing something like
Roger steps you've actually found a way
of doing the simulation which makes zero
overhead from Jordan big nur so we
actually now have a scheme for doing
this these simulations in a way that the
Jordan beginner schemes or overhead
doesn't enter at all
if you're looking at something like
qubit ization there's still a bit of
overhead from Jordan big nur but I think
that it's very advantageous to have a
lot of structure and the operators which
is simple to unpack and that's sort of
necessary because to implement the
operator that applies the unitary Zin
qubit ization you need to sort of do the
transformation on-the-fly in the sense
the logic is very simple for Jordan big
nur which makes it I think preferable
for those algorithms to probably Kataya
but I will say one thing which is in the
near term if you have a log end local
operator let's say you want to measure
the energy if you need to measure a log
and local operator and you have a fixed
measurement err then you have
exponentially less measurement err when
measuring that operator than if you have
an end local operator so in the near
term I think that a measurement side
there's advantages in using these
reduced locality things there's also
some other techniques James has some
techniques actually give you constant
locality and you know that's even sort
of undefined better in terms of
measurement error so
in the classical optimization part of
the parameters and vqe like for UCC
have you done much exploration how
different that's a great question we're
working a lot on that now actually so
we've done some studies I can tell you a
couple things I can tell you gradient
methods tend not to do very well because
there is some sort of stochastic noise
here so we've been looking mostly at
things like surrogate methods that
attempt to interpolate some model of the
energy surface and descend upon that and
those seem to work pretty well
[Applause]